Weegee origin of evil that's right they
made another one of these things the
first film was not only one of the worst
horror films of 2014 but one of the
worst films of that year period and when
I heard they were making a Ouija - my
reaction was something along these lines
but then I heard it was going to be
directed by Mike Flanagan the man who
made oculus a horror film that I find
very underrated as well as this year's
hush which debuted on Netflix earlier in
the year and suddenly things were
looking up Ouija origin of evil is about
a family that has recently gone through
a tragedy and this family runs a scam
they invite people to their house and
they try to make people feel like
they're communicating with the dead and
they think it's all cool they're making
a few bucks on the side until the mother
brings home a Ouija board one day and
the young daughter experiments with it
and things go to from there for the
family not for us as audience members
because this is genuinely one of the
best horror sequels ever made I walked
out of this film so happy this movie was
a breath of fresh air similar to most of
Mike Flanagan's movies because he has a
way of directing that is so against the
mainstream for horror not just in the
directing and editing style which I'll
get into in a second but in the way this
film recreates a retro feel the movie
takes place in the 60s and Flanagan is
dead set on making sure we feel like
we're watching a film that takes place
there not just in the costumes and the
cars and the fashion design and all of
those things but in the techniques used
in the film making right down to the old
universal logo that shows up in the
beginning that brought just a warm
feeling to me just from that the opening
title that booms onto the screen has the
date in Roman numerals at the very
bottom of the frame there's even a
little blip in the top right corner of
the screen to simulate how they used to
have those little black circles to tell
the projectionists when to switch reels
and when that scene does change there's
even a little jump in the frame you look
for it you can see these little dots
come in to the upper right-hand corner
of the screen in the industry we call
them cigarette burns now a lot of people
aren't even going to notice these small
touches they're just going to fade into
the background for most viewers but for
people who notice these things that is
so cool the fact that Flanagan took the
time to set up these little things to
really
recreate the idea that you're watching a
movie that was even maybe made in the
sixties even though we know it wasn't
but did the whole feel of it all just
harnesses that he gives so much
fine-tune precision to the way shots are
cut together there is a great level of
silence throughout this film there is an
amazing lack of jump-scares what he does
in this movie to scare you is so unique
and made me so happy
in this film when he cuts to something
horrifying he just puts it on the screen
he does not accompany it with a loud
blast of music telling us that we should
be scared this music in horror films
commonly tells us how to react whenever
there's a big boom
we call them jump scares this music
tells us that we should be scared
he chooses to cut to something
horrifying and just place it on the
screen with dead silence and so whatever
you're seeing you then have a natural
reaction to it which for me was chills
on a number of occasions rather than
relying on a loud and hilariously
bombastic score to sell his scares he
allows excellent sound design and
perfect editing along with our natural
inclination to be terrified by something
that just sort of appears in front of us
without warning the performances in this
movie are also top-notch the young girl
from oculus who I am so glad to see in
another film gives another fantastic
performance here the even younger girl
who is being infected by the things
surrounding this Ouija board was creepy
as hell she really sold it this is where
a child performance could be
unintentionally funny because of some of
the things that she's asked to say but
because of how well this film is
directed and because of the way the
other actors play off this little girl
yeah I'm gonna see her in my nightmares
Elizabeth reser as the mother who's
witnessing all these horrifying things
happen to her family was also fantastic
henry thomas gets a really meaty role as
a priest who works for the school who
gets involved with this as well what's
also so great is that this film
highlights characters over scares it
takes its time to set up real people you
genuinely do start to care for these
girls who are in this struggling
family and so when scary stuff really
gets nasty towards the third act it
highlights their emotional reaction to
these horrifying things rather than just
having a whole bunch of stuff pop out at
you the fact that you are emotionally
invested in these characters towards the
end makes the scares even greater
because there's an emotional depth
behind it and the backstory that is
eventually revealed for me it really
worked because a lot of times in horror
movies there's always this moment where
somebody goes well this is what you're
dealing with yep sorry some
happened once and I guess you're kind of
screwed while this film does fall into
that it's kind of expected and this film
does it in the best way you could in a
way that is genuinely startling and
again creepy and that's what this movie
really was for me just a very unsettling
film that on a number of occasions gave
me goosebumps for real and this film
just so cleverly builds and builds and
builds this movie understands what I
talked about in my video for the problem
with horror movies today that horror
movie should be like sex what I said in
that video was that you don't want to
blow your load too early crude but true
you want to have your audience teased
you want to have them feeling like
they're on the edge and then finally at
the end you just let everything hit and
that's what this movie does so well it
doesn't let you off easy jump scares in
films generally they happen and you go
ah gah feels good and then all the
tension is gone this movie doesn't give
you that release that is clever
filmmaking now I have two minor issues
with this movie one is that there is a
CGI image in the middle of the movie
that to me betrayed the retro feel of it
all and took me out of the 1960s 1970s
feel that they were really going for
it's not a major complaint but it did
take me out of the moment for a minute
and the other is that during the second
act there might be a five six seven
minute period where I felt the tension
drained but it picks up again very
quickly this movie impressed the hell
out of me Mike Flanagan has continued to
impress me as a director I really really
genuinely kind of loved Ouija origin of
evil I'm as surprised as you I'm going
to give this movie an A
what can I say this is one of the best
horror sequels ever made that being said
the first one was really terrible but
still this is everything I want in a
horror movie good characters good
emotion good scares it did it for me
guys so guys I'm excited about two
things number one I'm going to be
releasing a video this Saturday that I
am so pumped to share with you every
single year my wife and I do a Halloween
special and this Saturday I'm going to
be releasing our fourth annual Halloween
special we did something super fun this
year we actually went to a cabin in the
woods in Tennessee and filmed a very
cool selection of various horror movies
along with an inter woven short film
that proceeds throughout the video I'm
going to be releasing that this Saturday
please do check it out we worked very
hard on it and I'm going to be releasing
a special movie review on Halloween Day
this year I'm really looking forward to
that you guys are the best thank you so
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]